this morning The Washington Post reports
new allegations of sexual misconduct by
former CBS this morning anchor Charlie
Rose CBS News fired Rose in November
after eight women connected with his PBS
program claimed that he had groped them
exposed himself or spoke to them
inappropriately
tarika Duncan is here with the new
allegations that according to the
newspaper show a much wider pattern of
harassment Jericka good morning good
morning the Post reports 27 women
including 14 CBS News employees said
Rose sexually harassed them over a more
than 30 year period the paper alleges
over that time roses behavior was
flagged to managers at the network is
earliest 1986 and as recent as April of
2017 when Rose was a co-anchor of the
show and one example when Rose worked
for 60 minutes in 2013 an employee says
he grabbed her buttocks as he walked
down the office hallway there is no
indication that incident was reported to
management
most recently former CBS this morning
employee Brooks Harris left to work at
roses PBS show where she says she
experienced a number of unwanted sexual
advances and comments she claims she was
encouraged to take the job by CBS this
morning executive producer Ryan Cade Roe
The Post says Cade Rose former assistant
allegedly reported concerns to Cade row
about roses behavior toward Harris Cade
Roe denied being warned about
inappropriate behavior by rose to Harris
and says he did not encourage her to
take the job with Rose in a statement
CBS News said since we terminated
Charlie Rose we've worked to strengthen
existing systems to ensure a safe
environment where everyone can do their
best work CBS News president David Rohde
said in a statement we have continued to
investigate a number of issues several
important steps have already been taken
including adding in-person training
around misconduct and this training is
mandatory we've conceived or convened
rather a working group of colleagues to
report issues and handle problems as
management CBS News corporate office
reported in November
that it never received complaints of
sexual harassment by Charlie Rose until
after his termination the corporate
office hasn't revealed how many women
have stepped forward since then Anthony
Eureka Thank You Jericka very disturbing
news this oh my gosh Anthony I have a
very bad case of deja vu who I have to
say you know I feel sick to my stomach
and I don't know what to say about this
you know when the story first broke I
said Charlie was my friend I still
consider him a friend I know that's
really not the politically correct thing
to say at this moment but I don't
believe in abandoning friends when
they're down that said this is very
troubling very disturbing and you can't
discount what these women are saying I
know all of the men who are mentioned in
the management the management that
they're saying they're - I have great
respect for them and this is what I know
I don't know what more we can do -
Charlie Rose except a public flogging
he's gone he's not coming back to CBS
News Norah O'Donnell John Dickerson and
I are the new team we are working very
hard here I know that we bring up
quality broadcast surrounded by a
quality team and all we can continue to
do is do the best possible possible job
that we can but you see these
allegations you hear the stories and it
just makes you sick all over my portion
I don't know what to do had to handle
this story for I just want us to move
forward I want us to do the best job
that we can but that said you can't
ignore what these women are saying
that's also part of my anguish here
don't you know that women were hurt and
are saying the things that they're
saying and I think it's good that we're
having this conversation
27:27 new women in the one yes as we
said we would be covering this story and
of course we yeah we and we will cover
it that's the thing we're not running
away Frank
we are not running away from it